bonjour emmanuel gallicher merci de
répondre à ces quelques questions sur
france 24 vous êtes maître de
conférences sciences et technologies
nucléaires au cnam les autorités
ukrainiennes estiment que la mission de
la nasa pour i jah est la plus difficile
de l'histoire de lagence pour quelle
raison est ce que vous partagez ces
inquiétudes
mais parce qu'effectivement c'est là la
centrale se trouve dans une zone de
guerre donc là yoann n'est jamais allé
inspecter un site nucléaire en zone de
guerre donc c'est pour ça que c'est très
inquiétant il faut absolument qu'il y
ait un arrêt des combats total pour que
les experts puissent arriver jusqu'à la
centrale ce sera quoi la mission de
lagence de l'iowa exactement asa
porridge as qu'elle pourra éloigner les
risques
ah oui je crois certainement qu'elle va
pouvoir éloigner les risques simplement
la première chose elle va déjà faire un
état des lieux des tous les systèmes de
l'état d'endommagement ou pas des
systèmes de sûreté de sécurité nucléaire
donc déjà ça ça va nous donner une bonne
évaluation qui sera indépendante parce
que jusqu'à aujourd'hui on avait les
paroles de deux ukrainiens la parole des
russes aujourd'hui on a besoin d'un état
des lieux indépendants complètement
transparent et neutre de l'état deux
accords hijja donc ça c'est sera
extrêmement important et puis aussi voir
le conditions de travail des opérateurs
de la centrale ça ça sera aussi
fondamental c'est quoi le principal
risque aujourd'hui sur la centrale de
japon ridja que les systèmes de
refroidissement ne répond plus
oui je pense que le principal risque il
est sur un dommage mans de
l'alimentation électrique qui
engendrerait des problématiques sur le
refroidissement le deuxième risque je
dirais c'est aussi le stress des
opérateurs et donc c'est pour ça c'est
le troisième pilier vous rappelez début
mars la lui avait mis en place sept
piliers pour que la sûreté de la
centrale soit en bon état on avait vu
que le troisième pilier c'était vraiment
qu'il y ait une sérénité et aucune
entrave au travail des opérateurs donc
ça je dirais que c'est le deuxième
risque finalement sûre cette centrale
emmanuel galice et les russes
disent vouloir accorder la centrale les
apories déjà au réseau électrique russe
à la crimée c'est quoi leur intérêt
je pense que c'est simplement d'avoir
d'électricité en plus ils ont ils ont on
a tous des problématiques de l'énergie
électrique et notamment on en aura cet
hiver donc ça leur permettrait
évidemment déjà de nous en d'en donner
moins à leur belligérants à l'ukraine à
l'heure et demie entre guillemets et
puis en donner à la crimée et à la
russie aussi l'énergie nucléaire je vous
rappelle et une énergie peu cher père m
stable dans le temps et donc elle est
très très importante pour tous les pays
et de le risque de changer de réseau
d'électricité c'est quoi
le risque je dirais deux plus grands ce
serait un plaque d'art
un blackout merci aisée moi c'est ça
c'est une opération qui était possible
mais c'est une opération qui doit être
fait dans avec certaines procédures
protocole on enlève pas d un réseau
électrique d'une centrale et on
reconnaît à une autre il faut c'est
aussi sûr que le réseau qui relie la
centrale à la crim est un qui est qui et
qui n'a pas été utilisé puis 2014 et en
bon état donc il ya plein de chez plein
de procédures industriel avec quelques
risques avant de pouvoir connecter à
notre réseau électrique on ne connaît
pas en tout cas à l'heure où les le
risque d'un accident nucléaire a zappé
aurait déjà on s'est passé il est élevé
ou pas et on ne connaît pas les risques
pour la population
si on les connaît pour l'instant les
zones où il aligna de la radioactivité
dans les coeurs de réacteurs n'ont pas
été touchées n'ont pas été endommagés on
a on a une sûreté totale là-dessus
puisque vous savez que le cren fait
partie du réseau européen au niveau de
la de l'environnement pour lutter la
surveillance de l'environnement pardon
sur la radioactivité et on n'a aucun
capteur qui nous dit qu'il ya eu une
élévation de la radioactivité quelques
quelque part donc pour l'instant la
sûreté des réacteurs est totale merci
beaucoup pour ces précisions emmanuel
gallicher maître de conférences au cnam
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions